hi guys I want to show you how to get
the Aero Snap feature from windows 7 in
Windows Vista first of all open your
internet browser and go to a common
search engine such as Google and type in
Aero snap for this stuff sorry I spelled
that wrong again the first thing will be
the mysterious their mysterious OS comm
where you can get your snap for Vista
and XP yes this will work for Vista and
XP for either one and straight out of
Windows 7 click for this to finish this
is where you can download the sorry the
windows 7 era that this one is normal TV
comm hopefully this will have the
download link yes second I thought it is
that a SK VG calm and I guess I'll post
this link in the description so everyone
can you know click on it and get it
because they know they'll be loving this
you find it it's down here a download
link and this is the Windows 7 Aero Snap
feature where you can minimize maximize
and resize the window by dragging and
dropping it to screen corners I'm not
gonna click it because I actually
already have it so I'm going to this is
what it looks like in your Start menu
it's already running and it'll be in
your system tray looking like this one
right here right-click it you can close
it or get information about it so here's
what it looks like in action say I have
a notepad and an internet browser open
at the same time or - and in a browser
guide to the left should I go on to the
right and you can compare them instantly
isn't that nice just drag it right back
off then I'll resize itself drag it back
to the middle it'll resize itself if you
want to maximize a window it's simple
drag it to the top it fits the screen
and you'll still have transparency you
can see my rocket dock back there and
drag it off the top and it's back to
normal size and I think to close a
window
it doesn't work that's the old school
anyway it's the same as double clicking
except it'll it looks cooler drag it to
the left obviously so I think it's a
handy feature it's cool windows
management works well in Windows 7
say I want to be dragging I'm gonna copy
some files from my documents to my
computer just drag it over here still up
beta remember and drag this one right
here and there you go you can compare
straightaway you can see what's in your
single one so I like it actually it's
pretty cool I hope you like this
tutorial and go ahead and demo that yes